after nearly five years of production
Ford has given its successful c-max
minivan an extensive facelift and what's
under the hood has changed to
particularly noticeable is the
redesigned front the big radiator grille
with lots of chrome creates more
presence
but the redrawn headlights seem more
delicate than in the predecessor model
also striking is the rising side contour
of the c-max the rear lights have a
large clear but somewhat arbitrary
design Ford has converted all its
engines to fit the Euro six emissions
standard our test car is powered by the
new 1.5 litre EcoBoost gasoline engine
despite its modest capacity the
four-cylinder engine produces 110
kilowatts and as a maximum torque of 240
Newton meters Klaus Christoph aja from
the German Auto Club ADAC says the
engine is pleasantly quiet unless you
rev it up too much what you don't need
to
thanks to turbo charging the c-max
drives as you'd expect from a Ford
comfortable overt long distances but
still agile weight distribution and the
c-max isn't as good as it used to be but
in a slalom test the car still avoids
the traffic cones well with ESP
interventions and our test car can break
from 100 kilometers an hour to a full
stop in just 36 metres
up to five people fit comfortably in the
Ford c-max even the rear seats have
enough leg and Headroom the trunk boasts
460 litres of space or 830 with the rear
seats down the instrument panel is
easier to survey and many functions are
simpler to operate
unfortunately the rear view is somewhat
obstructed by the broad c-pillars at the
German Auto club's eco test and the
c-max consumed an average of six point
four liters of premium fuel over 100
kilometers Ford rates the car at 6.1
liters but the difference is negligible
the c-max has a top speed of 204
kilometers an hour
it's Klaus Christoph I hear from the
German Auto Club says the Ford c-max
cuts a good figure with its fresh design
roomy interior and modern engines our
test car with top equipment goes for at
least 25,000 euros those who want even
more room can go for the grand c-max it
has a longer wheelbase room for seven
people and sliding doors
you